yeah okay so whether whether it's like
when I was saying to George that any
year will be a world connor than a year
after that would be nominated you go or
any of this stuff it's basically have an
idea in your head so it starts with the
creative idea so it might be i want to
do this big story of setting out of
space about how we go out into the solar
system ended up with the Stars and you
know so you start with that as an ocean
that's then comes okay how am I gonna
get this done how many it gets made and
this like that becomes okay Who am I
going to pull together how am I gonna
get it give money how what the logistics
that is how am I gonna get this out the
world because for me my goal is a writer
is taken emotional truth from my life
and communicate it authentically and
well to a large audience and for me
that's a hundred hundreds of thousands
or millions of people so for me it just
speaking personally doing something at
the 99-cent the 99-seat theater won't
serve my objective because I want to get
it out on a big stage so that's where
the internet is so great you have each
millions of people but so what so it
starts with the idea then it becomes the
execution then it becomes the
distribution and so previously it was
always the studios or networks but now
it can be the internet it can be video
and demand it can be a lot of other
methods and so I'm enormously grateful
with this new tech needs new technology
some emerged digital cameras final cut
on a Mac all this stuff the good part
instantly is I'm proud of myself is that
I'm happy to embrace the new
technologies I'm not a lot of my friends
wow there's someone mention the way
things used to be that they can't learn
the new methods they can't embrace the
new ways of doing things and so they get
stuck where they're dependent on the
studios to make their dreams come true
and that
sometimes it works and it's hurting for
my friend Rockne O'Bannon he's got two
shows shows two new shows on network
great that's fine but for most people it
doesn't work and and they're just you
know getting ahead against a wall and so
again if you if you know what you're
doing it for then you can remove a lot
of things that aren't serving
you